To analyze the statistical significance of
the identified peptide spectrum matrix.
We will introduce the concept
of Spectral Dictionaries.
Imagine that a PSM search
of 1,000 spectra from
a human sample against the human
proteome results in 100
peptide spectrum matches whose
score exceeds a threshold.
What is a fraction of erroneous
peptide spectrum matches among
these 100 peptide spectrum matches?
I'll give you a hint of how it may
be possible to answer this question,
and here's the hint.
Let's repeat the same experiment for
a randomly generated
DecoyProteome of the same
size as the human proteome.
Of course, we don't care about
peptide spectrum matches
identified in the Decoy Proteome:
there are simply statistical artifacts.
What we care about is the number
of such hits in the Decoy Proteome.
For example, if you identify 5 peptide
spectrum matches in DecoyProteome,
then you expect that five over 100,
or 5% of
PSMs identified in the real
proteome are incorrect.
And therefore, we define the notion of
"false discovery rate" as simply the ratio
of the number of peptide spectral
matches identified in DecoyProteome
over the number of peptides spectral
matches identified in the real proteome.
And when we run this experiment
on the T-Rex spectra, then
we will identify 27 peptide spectrum
matches in the UniProt+ real database
and only 1 peptide spectrum
match in the DecoyProteome of
the same size for a threshold of 100.
Which means that, in this experiment,
FDR will be a respectable 3.7%.
But does it mean that we just found
approximately 27 T-Rex peptides?
Not quite, because many of the peptides
that we identify are simply
laboratory contaminants
that are present in every experiment.
For example, keratin from human skin.
There are currently millions of
tiny particles of my skin and
skin of the people who pass through this
room floating in the air in this room.
The questions that we have to answer to
figure out which of the identified peptide
spectrum matches are correct
is how to estimate
the statistical significance of
individual peptide spectrum matches
rather than the bulk false discovery
rate for the entire sample?
To answer this question,
we will bring in a monkey.
Give this monkey a typewriter and
let the monkey type random keys on this
typewriter for a very long time.
Afterwards, let's check how many correctly
spelled English words the monkey generated.
We can use Webster dictionary to check it,
or whatever monkey dictionary to check it.
In this particular case, the monkey
generated 13 correctly
spelled English words.
Does it mean that the monkey can spell?
Well to answer this question
we probably need to evaluate
what is the expected number or
words from the dictionary
that appear in a randomly
generated text or in other words,
we need to solve the following:
The Monkey and the Typewriter Problem.
Find the expected number of strings
from a dictionary appearing
in randomly generated text.
But what does it have to do
with mass spectrometry?
Well, at the same time, we want to solve
the following mass spectrometry problem:
To find the expected number of high-scoring
peptides, which is to find the expected
number of high-scoring peptides against
a given spectrum in a decoy proteome.
The input to this problem is a Spectrum,
an integer n, and a score threshold.
And the output is the expected
of peptides in a decoy proteome
of length n that score a least
threshold against Spectrum.
You may be wondering what is there
similarity or any relevance of the expected
number of the high-scoring peptide problem and
the monkey and the typewriter problem.
It is not clear that these
problems are equivalent, but they are.
To explain why this is
actually the same problem,
I will introduce the notion
of spectral dictionary.
Dictionary of spectrum under
a given threshold is simply the set
of all peptides with a score of at
least threshold against Spectrum.
There will be many of these peptides,
and as soon as the generate
the dictionary for
a given spectrum, we can reformulate
the expected number of high-scoring
peptides problem as the following problem.
We want to find the expected
number of peptides from Dictionary
occurring in a decoy proteome of length n.
And let's make one more step
to reformulate this problem.
We've reformulated its output.
Let's now reformulate its input.
And the new input will be simply all
peptides from Dictionary of Spectrum and
an integer n.
And output, the expected number
of strings from the dictionary
occurring in a decoy proteome of lens F.
Take a look at this problem.
This is exactly the monkey and
the dictionary problem for
a specific set of peptides
given by dictionary or
spectrum under a given threshold.